you know what you know what little baby
got a little dirt don't got what hits
like actually yeah tell me one hit like
a real hit I'm not talking about
screaming I'm not talking about in the
streets in the club on tomorrow you got
in the car and the radio was on I'm not
talking about laughing I'll cry later I
was just yo what about what I was just
about yo what the [__] that is a Drake
song I was about to say I sold a drink
whose song was that tell me the little
Dirk song that has been an actual hit it
doesn't exist but what's up I'm talking
about like top 10 on billboard by
himself
but this is why I like babies
little baby got 15 of those you know
what I love about Derek though it's his
story because he's been he's like you
know like he's he's evolved so much in
front of our eyes
he's missing the hit record though I
think it'll separate him you know